it's very easy to blame Donald Trump for
everything terrible in the world but
that's just ridiculous
there's also Mike Pence and it turns out
the GI Joe doll left out in the Sun who
is our vice president has a secret
identity Jonny Quest bodyguard race
Bannon there is guy maybe a little more
like master race Bannon mayor has
noticed Pence's resemblance to the 60s
cartoon star and they're using
screenshots of old Jonny Quest episodes
to show Pence's secret adventurous life
like this one Mike Pence luring some
gays out for some electroshock
reprogramming the only the only thing I
can think of here is does the carpet
match the drapes
that's not very creative and the answer
is it probably does but you got to roll
that carpet up every time
hey balls do not get pretty when they
age I mean like they're really hot when
they're younger you've been doing
comedians we're gonna show you a photo
from Mike Pence's cartoon adventures and
for 250 points I want you to answer a
question about it first up Mike Pence's
approach to Asian relations comedians
what martial art is Mike Pence a black
belt in run fat shaming
lúcia Krav Maga
next one next one
Yui Spence helping this guy what are
they doing run that's actually how you
feed Donald Trump's fish tank Moshe he's
not helping him he's restraining him so
he can't jerk off to gay porn